my name is Neil Ferguson I'm Lawrence a
tish professor of history at Harvard but
I'm also William Ziegler professor of
business administration at Harvard
Business School and I am a senior fellow
of the Hoover Institution at Stanford
and of Jesus College Oxford i was born
in Glasgow in 1964 and I grew up in an
atmosphere of I suppose late Calvinism
crossed with the Scottish enlightenment
my parents were both scientists they
were rationalists and our rationalists
and encouraged me to think of the world
in the terms that had been in so many
ways pioneered in 18th century Scotland
if I took a day off school my father
would hand me a copy of Adam Smith the
wealth of nations and say you should use
this time usefully read that and so I
guess I acquired from early on his work
ethic max Faber was right about
Protestants and work at least where the
west of scotland was concerned but i
think that was tempered by a kind of
skepticism that Scotland produced rather
later in the 18th century
I was very small indeed when my father
took a job in nairobi I think I was all
of two years old and we lived there for
two years so this was in my early early
childhood my earliest memories are of
Africa and of its extraordinary
luminosity this became much more
powerful as a memory in contrast with
the dreary gray cold Glasgow that we
returned to when I was turning five I
can't say that at the age of four I had
very sophisticated political insights I
don't think I then knew the difference
between a colony and an independent
state which Kenya had only just become
so I'm not sure that I can claim that
those childhood experiences had a very
profound effect on my thinking as an
historian but they did implant in me are
passionate visceral love of that part of
the world and whenever i go back to East
Africa I'm amazed at the power of these
deep childhood memories i have i have my
pristine moments exclusively in africa
Oh